all right it is now time for paul's
picks thanks to taylormade productions
for sponsoring this segment summer is in
full swing and entertaining expert paul
zone is back with us with his must-haves
to keep you glowing and going this
season welcome back thanks for having me
there's a lot going on this time of year
right a lot going on okay whether it's
for your skin or whether you're going
shopping or events
yes yes let's start with skincare
skincare with this wonderful duo from
olay with their niacinamide plus peptide
24. okay so what this is going to do
it's going to help with the wrinkles
it's going to help hydrate because it's
so hot and so dry here in las vegas so
it's going to help with that it's going
to help to correct uneven tones and it's
healthier looking skin with 99 pure
niacinamide and you might say paul why
is this in the package because it's a
2-pack and if you pop into sam's tub
yes if you pop into sam's club you get
eight dollars off between now and august
7th and that's just one time application
at night put it on put it on the morning
at night get that hydration going we
need it all right what's next speaking
of hydration next up we have some back
to school meals made easy with smart
finals so i love smart and final it is
one trip and that's it they have
everything you need
including this line called sun harvest
which is organic and it's much more cost
effective and they also have a green
line of things like compostable forks
and spoons in detergent and everything
like that so it's better for your wallet
and it's better for mother nature
breakfast is made easy right here with
some granola and some peanut butter nut
clusters we got some peanut butter so
you know one click and that's it if you
go to smartinfinal.com and they have an
app so download the app and you'll love
it smart final makes it easy yes they
make it so easy so easy and what about
the summer drink oh yeah next up we have
absolute so absolute has teamed up with
garcelle bouvier to create this fun
front yard citrus situation here so you
know absolute vodka is a perfect
cocktail for any summer soiree so
they've created this cooler together
inspired by the different flavors so
this is the lime they have grapefruit
they have citron they have a wide
variety of different flavors of coolers
and so not only is it a table but it's
also a cooler so you fill this with ice
and everybody go to the front yard get
together have an absolute cocktail and
really celebrate that's a great backyard
the balcony where can you get that you
can get this at reserve bar dot com
order it and then it's a great gift too
for a summer story
i definitely i agree i agree okay next
up summer shopping summer shopping back
to school back to school the kids are
going back to school well jcpenney has
you covered it's your one stop shop for
all things back to school for the kids
they have a wide variety of items from
classics like this fun denim jacket
right here they have denim pants they
have these cute shoes and they're such
great prices you can go to jcpenney or
jcp.com and they have all they have
husky they have adaptive clothes so it's
really for every kid in every ability
and they have coupons i love a good
coupon at jcpenney.com because hello
everybody's on the budget this time of
year right exactly exactly and back to
school for the kids but also for the
parents too
too all right and last but certainly not
least um coffee cocktails i love a
coffee cocktail so we have some liqueur
43 so this is the most popular spanish
liqueur in the world it's 43 natural
ingredients and i get a lot of vanilla
from it so it makes a wonderful cocktail
called the carrijo so it's a shot of
espresso a shot of the liqueur 43 and
it's absolutely delicious and we also
have a horchata with liquor 43 that is
actually vegan so it's delicious you can
do a fun little pina colada with that
you can pick these up at total wine or
drizzly has been my best friend the past
couple years you go on drizzly app and
they will deliver it to you you can have
wonderful cocktails you have the best
tips that's why you're the entertaining
expert okay thank you so much paul for
being here thank you these are great all
right we will send it to break and we'll
come right back